this used to be arable so this would
have been winter wheat 18 years ago at
neb castle estate they've been rewilding
the land before anyone really knew what
it meant the soil too unprofitable to
grow produce is ideal for handing back
to mother nature
and now a welcome cash subsidy courtesy
of british taxpayers for continuing what
they're doing
this is the most important thing for 40
years i guess i mean you know it's a
culmination of years and years and years
of thinking and and discussing and
hopefully influencing some of the
decision making but you know wow it's
amazing
it's the biggest shake-up of britain's
landscape in a generation says the
government a billion dollar funding
scheme designed firstly to incentivize
sustainable farming and secondly to
reverse the decline of nature by paying
landowners to re-wild their properties
all possible since the uk left the eu's
common agricultural policy that
subsidise farmers depending on the size
of their land
the new post-brexit funds designed to
reward farmers for making
environmentally positive choices
we have now legally binding targets for
the environment most notably a target to
reverse the decline in nature
by 2030
and we have a responsibility as a
government to ensure that the payment
rates we make are attractive enough
to incentivize the uptake of our schemes
but there are rumblings of concern why
is the plans will simply reward already
wealthy farmers that have land to spare
concerns too about the lives and
livelihoods of smaller tenant farmers
who could be kicked off land to make way
for rewilding schemes
and what about food security say farmers
britain needs more not less farmland to
feed a growing population or run the
risk of being increasingly dependent on
foreign and potentially lower quality
imports
delivering food for the country is also
an absolutely crucial part of what we do
so it must be delivering food alongside
environmental delivery rather than
instead of
it's raised questions about the future
of farming how to balance sustainability
and food production this might be the
answer not an agricultural revolution
but something that's been done for
centuries small local farms close to
urban areas
agriculture is at a crossroads and the
more land that's handed over to nature
in return for government subsidies in
the coming years means that we may come
very soon to rely upon local producers
like this to feed our communities
we live in a world shaped by food and
the land it's grown on
nature's future is our future
nevarka al jazeera south east england